I like I'm Aaron elm street and I like
new nightmare those are the only two
that are directed by wes craven yeah I
do want to see new nightmare I actually
was just like reading stuff about it
yesterday because like all this stuff
came out by wes craven because the new
screen movie I'm saying red eye I was
like just about to ask you that have you
yeah that's like one of my favorite
movies of ledge under yeah when I first
saw that movie like it was I don't know
how old I was probably 11 or 10 or so I
was like obsessed with it like oh they
don't like I ever like been into a movie
as well as much I was that movie when I
first saw it that's hilarious cuz I I
saw that in theaters and I was like I
forget sometimes our age difference
because I was a lot older than 10 well
if he meant 2005 did it yeah yeah so I
was like 11 probably I was 17 yeah I
didn't see them in theater I saw it on
DVD when it came out and I was like
doing crazy while watching it when this
is so awesome that Kelly and murph anak
the acting is really really really good
in the movie is oh my discovery of
killing Murphy having extreme Irish
accent I just have to throw that out
there he really does yeah there was a
new potatoes not in the farm in on that
I have found the potentials and I like
oh my god or so I was like oh my word i
can't understand a word you're saying
yeah everyone no one else would know
about this but i i'm not a movie from
netflix called intermission an irish
film was really really good but Killian
Murphy's the lead and I had to turn on
subtitles because of everyone's accent
was pretty extreme than movie but him
especially like I could not understand
like anything he was saying and I do it
I don't know why he would put in a
situated accent because he is from
Ireland I read so I guess that's his
real voice um it's like crazy it just
like makes them all the better actor as
you would like never really guess that
watching him in movies she just goes to
a restaurant
what can I get your server how about a
closer without the potatoes on the stink
of take the table to feel like it's a
movie like he's saved like the most like
simple things we can understand like in
the beginning the movie he is saying me
and Deirdre broke up he's like man
teaser broke oh and he's saying a few
weeks let's friends like when did this
happen e same a few weeks back he's like
a few baseball that's crazy he's like
Oscar man geez your ruco but what a big
block this is your spot and my whole
thing about the Irish accent is that
everything sounds like a question that's
what you have to remember if you had
imitation of an Irish it sounds like a
question everything sounds like a
question right now it's pretty cold
outside I got my hair cut the other day
everything's a question hey yeah ha ha
ha ha that would be Canadian Donna who
likes Canada few people like Canada
those people are for losers I like
Canada but it sucks I like Canada yeah
Heather they got donuts up there doe
does bacon curly and hockey that's it
bexley actually neve campbell was born
in in canada and so is Rachel McAdams so
that's some good stuff right there doug
campbell sucks I thought she was great
well in this one she was pretty good bye
remember life although as much like I
liked the expression of the first two
films like she kind of annoyed me
because she was like to see my pretty
one note to me like she'd always just
like have like like just like this face
it's like the same face always just
ahead like that's like
aching like an eight-second like she's
just gonna like explode from how scared
she is coming sooner or later she's
gonna toughen up a little bit oh she
toughened up in this movie yeah this one
my nose waiting for the same crap over
over again to this one should i freakin
like at one point is like charges the
killer like her no reason at all ha yeah
she was awesome like there's that stayed
were like like I'm not trying to give it
the way like a murder is taking place
and there's absolutely no reason for her
to approach it but she chooses to yes
when that happened I was like dang i
don't know if i do that if i return to
me he's like what the heck is she doing
but well I think sometimes I don't want
to over analyze the screen films but I
think sometimes I mean they're they're
going for this the cliches like they're
making fun of them in in horror movies
everyone always goes outside when they
wouldn't in real life and you know they
do all that stuff to make it more scary
in a movie but in real life everyone
would be like in the corner but that
makes for a boring movie anyway yeah I
just liked how this one there was like
always like a new idea in my mind of who
the killer is and that purse would be
killed off of date oh is it I literally
think it's almost impossible to guess
who it is I mean like of course that
possible but I mean it's insane I was
like almost positive like I was turning
my friend I was going crazy how so proud
of myself like I was like almost certain
that I figured out who it was and then
like right when I was thinking that the
person that I was like what yeah yeah
they're gonna come back to life they're
faking death I was like I was still
holding on to that but after a while I
gave it her all right well we should
probably sign off but I don't want to
well if you really want to keep talking
we can stop the podcast and then keep
talking
I'm going to have to edit this then I
you know have to edit it you just upload
it rod reel no I mean I'm gonna have to
make like five parts no man just upload
one part of her I'd like to be able to
do that but you're not a partner right
there looking I will surpass your
subscribers eventually yes you probably
will i'll continue making videos about
Rebecca blood and I think that video
hilarious that for you like a lot of
people my school saw it like somehow I
think one of my friends post on YouTube
is people keep coming up being taught me
about it I'm like why is this the video
that gets noticed in the office somebody
posted on Facebook yeah a couple people
had noted so like a lot of people from
my school son it's just cuz that song
right now I'm so popular it's so stupid
you can't be mad about being popular
it's not like anyone actually likes it
like I seriously have not heard a single
positive thing about it but there's just
not that one white girl that goes like I
don't give it everyone so upset about I
think it's really catchy like I've heard
anything about the heck everyone's just
like God ever all older teens and
everyone else I'm sure a bunch of
ten-year-old girls are in love with it
thank you heard lame party yeah that's
return it anyway thank unify us bon bon
you're just encouraging me to turn this
off even more looking forward to the way
god good night Blake Kennedy thanks for
doing a podcast enjoy not understanding
die hard and predator and terminator get
off of it not understanding oh you don't
understand it at all okay anyway you're
awesome man alright man